so you remember mmm here's a picture in
case you forgot he's still mad at Donald
Trump because he won't respond to his
sad raps about the president that's an
awfully hot coffee pot should I drop it
on Donald Trump probably not but that's
all I got
racism's the only thing he's fantastic
for cuz that's how he gets his rocks off
that he's orange Oh Gramps is so
adorable anyway he just told the music
journalist that a quote blanking turd
would be a better president than Trump
Eminem says these things to agreeable
wimps ie music journalists who never
challenged their subjects if an artist
breaks wind they just giggle and write
how cool it smells Eminem also says
Trump supporters are brainwashed and
that a rich guy like Trump has no
business telling the non-rich anything
yet Eminem is also filthy rich using his
logic why should anyone listen to him
but my question to Emma
is this why rage when you can engage it
would be refreshing for him to actually
have a conversation with the people he
denigrates if he had the guts he'd make
his points better and not come off as an
irrelevant crank but he won't an
avoidance of debate reveals weakness in
one's own arguments but now jay-z has
knocked Trump and Trump responded back
that's got a kill mm apparently Van
Jones asked jay-z about the low black
unemployment rate under Trump jay-z
responded that it's not about money at
the end of the day isn't that weird
Pelosi jay-z Eminem all stupid rich one
says a thousand dollars is a crumb
another another says that a job isn't
important for happiness why is it only
the really rich say that because they
don't need either well except for Trump
he never says that maybe that's why he's
president and they aren't Kennedy you
are an alum of MTV I find it interesting
uh Van Jones I love him he's a very nice
man said that jay-z is a good role model
for Donald Trump because he grew in
public he was confessional and
vulnerable about his marriage I don't
think he had a choice in that Becky with
the good hair yes you know Beyonce had
to
right about these things and bring them
to the fore and there was a great amount
of internet and speculation as well as
in music journalism which you talked
about a little bit ago
what I find disingenuous is there are a
lot of issues and a lot of things that
jay-z can take to task and one of them
is the federal minimum wage but a lot of
people on the Left are pushing for
pushing for and who does that hurt the
most unemployed black teenagers and and
they have the hardest time entering the
workforce that's a real issue but saying
that money doesn't buy you happiness it
doesn't win you're rich yeah I mean a
statement like that shows that you can
be really rich and super miserable but
for those who have zero mobility and no
choices and no chance of moving up a
little bit of money and a nice job
sure would be refreshing considering how
the the cards have been stacked against
many people that jay-z is supposedly
defending yo want part of this is part
of the criticism to Donald Trump was
that he found trump's the s whole
comments to be hurtful has jay-z ever
listened to his own rap lyrics about
women yeah I don't I'm not a fan of that
kind of stuff I think it's misogynistic
and I don't I think it's damaging to
young black people but the biggest
audience is young white people I
actually FairPoint by simply by numbers
right not by percentage but there's just
a percent the most people who buy that
kind of music are white well because
blacks are what 13% of the population
but I'm saying even in terms of
percentages it's overwhelming who's
advanced number from which to therefore
pull a large wrong it's both in
percentage and absolute numbers the
white audience is bigger but I worry
about it in terms of the black audience
but okay but let me just say in response
to you that I think it was Donald Trump
who said wages are too high during the
campaign and he's still won so I don't
understand that but when it comes to
something like this being hurtful or
damaging right I don't see how you get
away from that that's what the man said
all right
Jesse I mean I love jay-z I just think
he's getting soft jay-z's you must not
need anything from him right listen to
your music and I don't listen to
anything else but you gots a deal
anymore so you don't need anything
Gregg I told you that in confidence
but I mean your feelings are hurt and
you're a rapper your feelings are hurt
come on man and then you're saying you
know the black unemployment you know
record low and he's saying it's it's not
about money every song he sings it's
about getting more money yeah
Trump stone is like polite Queen's
English his lyrics I think they have a
lot more in common than they realize
like that love money
they love women big mouths yeah you're
absolutely right you know what they are
they are actually equals they are
they're kind of like it's just a
different generation conversation
between the two of them I think they
would probably go play golf before Trump
became president James II would love to
hang out with right I mean it's just you
know it's super critical I think they
know jay-z obviously has a voice he's
very talented
but you know hey you could use that I
think in a lot more effective and
powerful ways to help in the black
community and as it relates to jobs and
whatnot at least the president he made a
promise he said he was gonna try to do
it and earn the votes and be able to
improve the unemployment numbers in the
black community and he's done that he's
delivered on his promise do you look at
some of the polling to black community
actually does support his immigration
policy so there you go